I'm so happy we're joined by Tucker
Carlson the host of Tucker Carlson
tonight and Tucker Carlson Originals on
Fox Nation now part one of his latest
two-part series Biden Inc is available
right now on Fox Nation and we got our
hands on an exclusive sneak peek
I want to know how corrupt a country is
take a look at how its leaders live do
the people in charge always wind up
richer than they were before they took
office do they live in sprawling
compounds surrounded by armed guards
does the average senator for example
live in the same zip code as the people
who vote for him places like Scranton
Pennsylvania if not you've got
corruption during his five decades as a
public servant Joe Biden and his family
became rich and they enriched themselves
with each country they supposedly served
how did they do that exactly we obtained
thousands of documents text messages
emails and recorded calls that tell the
story that illustrate how America's
first family really does business this
is Biden Inc
now Tucker like the Twitter Revelations
we discussed in that previous block
there's this stunning lack of curiosity
about everything the Biden family has
done to enrich itself why is that well
and it's long-standing it's 50 years of
ignoring how Joe Biden lived in this
sprawling estate in Greenville Delaware
owned by a former member of The Dupont
family on a government salary with no
other income like how did you do that
exactly then he moved to an even bigger
place and then he bought you know a
place on the shore on the Eastern Shore
in Rehoboth and then when he left the
vp's house he moved into one of the
biggest houses in the Potomac River in
McLean Virginia like how do who financed
all of this and of course nobody asked
those questions and by the way it's not
Joe Biden's not the only member of
Congress to get rich from so-called
public service but he's certainly the
most obvious example and we learned on
the laptop of course one of the ways he
got rich was by sharing a bank account
with his son who was selling access to
his father as the the vice president of
the United States to Ukraine and China
this seems like one of the biggest
stories of the past decade and I don't
think it's even been covered by the
biggest newspapers in the country which
really does tell you everything well
they try to distract from the underlying
narrative which is the bidens have
become become wildly wealthy trading off
Joe Biden's position in government by
just say oh well you're you're picking
on someone who's gotten through a
terrible addiction problem well just
because he's had personal problems
you're now piling on so they they go to
the salacious details which kind of get
the you know they're titillating they go
to the salacious details but that those
aren't really the point here are they I
mean they're they're kind of interesting
but that's not the core of what's going
on I mean it it's immaterial it's it's
actually sad I mean I knew Hunter Biden
I always kind of like Turner Biden and
it's it's sad to see him
totally disintegrate as a person hurt
other people and behave as he did like
an animal but that's definitely not the
story the story is how this family of
people with no obvious skills or
expertise in any area energy for example
they don't know anything about energy
like literally nothing and they're
making millions from a Ukrainian Energy
company like how did that happen and no
one's even asked and by the way I would
say most Americans at this point would
trade a little bit of corruption they
would tolerate a little bit of
corruption for some competence and
stability the most galling part of all
of this this is not Mayor Daley in
Chicago in 1965 who at least was plowing
the snow these are people who are
demonstrably terrible at running the US
government they're not good at it still
getting rich by selling access
to our government to our main enemy
China I mean it's it's too much
Tucker though this this Corruption of
the Biden family though of course it
doesn't have any effect on whether he's
going to seek re-election because
according to the New York Times Jill
Biden told president Emmanuel macron uh
at the White House estate dinner last
week that she and her husband are ready
for his re-election campaign and then
Biden then joined the French president
first lady in a playful toast now that
could have all been just
Sound and Fury signifying nothing but I
think they're going to go for it
they may I mean I've been consistently
surprised I confidently predicted on
television like eight times that Joe
Biden would not actually see his bid for
the Democratic nomination through
because I knew that his family members
were aware that he had dementia that he
was taking drugs in order to mask the
symptoms of dementia he was totally
incapable of serving as president so I
never thought that he would get the
nomination much less get to become the
president of the United States so like
I'm out of the prediction business on
this it's a pretty good deal for the
people who are actually running the
government Barack Obama and Susan Rice
Etc because there's nowhere in the way
Tucker is there a way for a populist
kind of whatever you want to call
America First America focused candidate
to really win on the national stage if
Republicans don't get this big Tech
under control by you know by breaking
this crazy Monopoly on speech that they
have and by getting early voting
mastered at the at the outset of these
elections is it possible for them to win
national office given the Electoral
makeup
well no of course and you know the some
of the the voting stuff is a question of
mechanics if we have this new system
Republicans if they want to be in the
politics business need to master it
that's obvious but on the question of
the control that Tech has over people's
minds not only Republicans not get
elected if that continues we won't have
a democracy you can't have a democracy
in a country in which information is
centrally controlled because people
don't have the information necessary to
make informed decisions so you know this
this is the actual threat to democracy
when the FBI tells a tech company to
hide information from voters three weeks
before an election that's not a
democracy it's less than a democracy
obviously yeah they talked about Russia
collusion what kind of collusion is this
this is within our own government Tucker
uh it's great to see you I saw you at
the Fox Nation Awards Patriot Awards
great which is so fun tonight and we
look forward to part two
thanks so much thank you appreciate it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else